is there something evil going on here
there's a neighborhood in los angeles
that
we need to talk about it's called skid
row
last month there was this really popular
true crime documentary on netflix it was
like the number one most
watched show here in the united states
and maybe around the world
and it was about this hotel that was
right here in skid row it's about a 21
year old canadian woman who disappeared
after exhibiting some very strange
behavior in an elevator
and yes there's going to be plenty of
spoilers here the hotel's cecil is
haunted and it's got some sort of
uncanny force the show is haunting and
confusing
and thrilling and an appalling and
insensitive abuse of
the power of documentary filmmaking the
whole series feels like a true crime
documentary
but there ends up being no crime at all
and the whole energy of this series is
founded on the idea that this hotel
is haunted with dark energy i think that
we're hoping
for a ghost because it's what we've come
to expect i'm here to tell you that the
cecil hotel
in los angeles doesn't have dark energy
that's a tantalizing but very lazy
explanation
and it exonerates the people and
policies that built
modern day la instead there's a much
bigger story here
one that the documentary decides to
largely ignore
or mischaracterize the story worth
telling here about this hotel
and the neighborhood in which it resides
is the story of how cities draw
boundaries these subtle borders that are
meant to contain the
city's least wanted people once you
understand what this looks like
and how it happened in la you can
understand how it happens in a lot of
cities
and it helps you understand what's
really going on
with the cecil hotel
it's the story of a city and a microcosm
of the american dream
okay first let's establish what and
where the cecil hotel is in la
here's downtown l.a and you have this
financial district here with all these
big buildings
a few streets over you have the cecil
hotel
right on the border of this 50 city
block neighborhood called
skid row right in the heart of downtown
l.a
go to skid road today and you are
quickly brought into the plight of
basic survival for nearly 5 000 homeless
people
the reason why i come in so many tents
out here because people can't afford
to live in a house nearly half of them
are considered to have
serious mental illness and life
expectancy here
is 48 years old 30 years less than the
u.s average
this small block of streets is
surrounded by highly developed districts
that every year become more shiny
and more expensive so how did skid row
this one small block of downtown become
where so many of the cities sick
and marginalized gathered
[Music]
way back when california was first taken
from mexico to become part of the united
states
loads of americans were moving west
moving to california
some of them were looking for gold and
some were just looking for a new start
the us used to be really good at
railroads and they built a railroad
across the entire country
that railroad ended right here in la
right in the location of modern day skid
row there is probably no
single area holding so much of charm and
beauty and the good
things of life as southern california so
you have a lot of people arriving
around this train station looking for
work this area developed a reputation as
being full of
transient people coming to the west with
dreams of gold and a new start and
instead
ending up with neither no jobs no homes
it was a part of town that no one wanted
to go los angeles counties has a
gregarious fun zone
where everybody has a good time as la
grew
so did the bad reputation of skid row
and so did the homeless population
the neighborhood was sort of for the
untouchables and when anyone considered
helping them or figuring out a policy to
solve this people resisted
one columnist of the day wrote quote
don't help this class
it is a crime against the community to
do so
the cecil hotel was eventually
constructed in the 1920s
right here on the outskirts of what was
becoming this undesirable part of town
at the time it was a grand hotel built
for business travelers
what turned the cecil hotel from this to
this wasn't dark energy or mysterious
forces
nor was it the fact that youtube played
a concert on the roof right next to the
cecil hotel in the late 80s
no no no no what happened to the cecil
hotel is something that happened to this
whole neighborhood
starting in the 1970s when city planners
and politicians
started re-envisioning downtown la
drawing lines
on maps to contain the growing
population of mentally ill
and homeless the goal here was to
bulldoze all the decaying buildings in
downtown
and to make way for a new business
district full of tall
shiny buildings the original demolition
plan included
skid row but the community leaders
fought back
saying listen city of la if you demolish
skid row without
solving the underlying issues you're
just going to have a bunch of smaller
skid rows
pop up scattered throughout the city
homelessness isn't going to go away
if you just bulldoze the neighborhood
the city was like yeah you have a point
so they agreed upon setting firm borders
that would be the quote containment zone
where the homeless and mentally ill
could stay so that the surrounding
neighborhoods could build nice
big office buildings without the
presence of these undesirable
populations
within skid row they constructed public
bathrooms
and benches and public spaces so that
as the city officials said those
amenities could quote
act as a magnet to hold the undesirable
population elements in
skid row undesirable population elements
wow that is just a fantastic way to take
human beings
and turn them into units
so weird even though the borders of skid
row based on the city plan were not like
walls they were just city streets
but the city planners made sure that
they would have quote strong
edges that will act as a buffer between
skid row
and the rest of the central city they
promised that
when skid row residents enter the buffer
the psychological comfort
of the familiar skid row environment
will be lost
so how did they do this one way they did
this is with harsh
lighting back in the old days they had
these historic lights on main street
which is one of the borders of skid row
they replaced those with like
harsh prison lights to make it very just
unpleasant to walk across the street
they put locks on the trash cans in the
surrounding districts so people wouldn't
leave skid row to come
scavenge for food residents of skid row
also
reported that police officers would be
patrolling these borders and anytime
someone would cross they would be
approached yet they would be left alone
for a time if they
stayed peaceful within the containment
zone all of this happened throughout the
70s 80s and 90s
as rent prices started to go up all
throughout this area
so rent is getting more expensive at the
same time funding for mental health
institutions was
drying up and the war on drugs
propagated by the reagan administration
was also heating up
skid row literally became a dumping
grounds for mental health institutions
who would drop off patients right here
knowing that
they would be contained the idea of
saving skid row
by drawing borders around it came from
the community leaders of skid row itself
it was a solution to keep affordable
housing keep the community intact but
soon the solution
was used as an excuse to neglect the
people within these lines
street cleaners and trash collectors
came less frequently than
in the rest of la city maintenance for
streets
sort of stopped showing up but the one
city resource that did show up in
abundance
was the police whose job it was to keep
these
quote undesirable population elements
within this zone
criminalizing the poverty inside these
lines and yes here's the cecil hotel
right within these firm containment
borders
so if you look at the cecil hotel under
this lens you now
see the danger the drugs the violence
not being caused by some creepy dark
energy that lured in
this woman from canada instead this was
the result
of a policy intentionally creating
borders within the city
to keep the city's problems contained
into one area
a spot that had real culture and
community values and history
and yet because of these dehumanizing
policies skid row
became defined as a series of statistics
and social problems
what i've found by looking into these
policies is that this wasn't an
inevitable course of action
the city could have put its money and
effort behind
the harder thing to do which is
addressing the underlying issues of
unemployment
mental illness drug addiction and
unaffordable housing stock
and yet the policy they pursued was
fixing
this problem with a band-aid using
policing and
the power of redevelopment the real
problems were swept under the rug to be
dealt with
another day keeping the city's problems
contained
neatly in this border and hiding them
from view
so let me tell you about the sponsor of
today's video
which is a thing that has let me watch a
bunch
more stuff on netflix that i wouldn't be
able to watch otherwise
expressvpn is a very affordable way to
not only protect your anonymity while
you are on the internet
but also allows you to expand your
entertainment options
basically what a vpn is is it allows you
to connect to the internet but like
via a different country so i'm in the
u.s but i can
like connect via canada or the uk
or india and now the internet thinks
that i'm in those countries
but also it allows you to expand the
stuff you're watching like a show like
brooklyn nine-nine
for example like i can watch stuff
that's only available in canada
here in the united states which is
pretty cool the crazy thing about this
though is that
it's really cheap like it's it's very
affordable
and you can actually get three months of
this for free so you can test it out and
check it out i've been using expressvpn
since probably 2016
and i find it to be a very useful and
easy service
one thing i use expressvpn for a lot is
when i travel i'm in a different country
and i don't want the internet to think
that i'm in that country because then it
blocks me out of my gmail account and
all of that
i've been traveling for a while but i'm
going to be starting soon i just got
vaccinated
so expressvpn is a fantastic way to keep
my internet connection
here in the united states while i'm
traveling there's a link in my
description when you click that link it
helps support this channel
but also click that link to find out how
you can get three months for
free zero money of expressvpn so you can
start getting in on some of these
benefits
thank you expressvpn for sponsoring this
channel thank you all for watching
lots more to come i have been all over
the place when it comes to
topics i feel like it's been russia a
lot of russia
i'm fascinated with russia lately it's
been
janet jackson it's been the us military
um skid row i just i'm all over the
place i've got a
really big story coming out early next
month
that i'm excited to share with you so
stay tuned
subscribe to my channel if you are not
subscribed i'll talk to you later
bye